[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cotonou
n'est pas une vie de tous en septembre
2010 la nomination de travailler à
l'aide le comité national des jeunes
amis
et
7 millions de la commune est le temps
des divisions ça après qu'un pas que
j'aille je touchais el cheikh avait
librement dans la première fois depuis
que c'est en deux temps
c'était important mais
ne vous y méprenez pas
l'avis de
masuku d'obstacles alors après cette
femme de m riant
nous allons confronter
adopté jeudi
par exemple
des clients
qui refusent de son fils patxi par
exemple nous allons travailler avec lui
wen jié nous avons animé les graves et
plusieurs mois m
le responsable refuse à 210 la maturité
pas obligé
de peaufinage ra hennessy
ça c'est notre vrai dans sa campagne
beaucoup d'autres organes
un deuxième client
avec qui nous a ramené si j'étais dans
ce pays
j'ai donc politiques de la place en qui
j'avais vraiment confiance une relation
j'ai tellement confiance en lui 2
d'autre m'a confié le magicien du
bramont crédits douteux
que je vous conseille jamais considéré
gens soient les progrès réalisés cette
fable
mais ce qui s'est passé l'événement est
un grand événement au palais nespoli
tragique événement a tellement que je
disais à l'appel du pape afin d'aider
benoît il avait sorti ma part j'ai tout
ça est juste arrivé de chine
après crédit nous rien
c'est pas mal
et pas par le la semaine dernière nous
allons livrer des travaux un client car
on refuse également
de
de réceptionner les travaux
étant la bataille
j'aimais tellement de poids
aujourd'hui la jeune fille parce que je
me sens bien plus vieux des jeunes à la
règle ici et je ne pouvais même plus
fait de moi un niveau plat jo linars et
bourges
d'orange
et quelques minutes après avoir eu
téléphone un public pendant sa campagne
j'étais motivé
voilà génial donc tout ça ce qu'on vous
dit quoi en fait ça vous dit me la vie
d'avant
sa fin de
programme
les grands traits de vie qui montrent
que l'activité toute attaque de viadeo
il ya de mal
donc on n'aime pas il faut travailler
doublement couturier mais aussi dans mon
héros c'est pas le temps de respirer par
défaut car et deux femmes plus de base
des faits
mais c'est quand il foire a peur d'elle
c'est quand la lumière ils ont eu droit
à des situations
cédé sa couronne s'est pas cantonné
combative amateurs quand on est en haut
pauline confiant
voilà
alors
emmené ici
[Applaudissements]
j'avoue que noté noah personnalité la
côte d'ivoire je sais que beaucoup
parlent
connaître la personnalité il ya monsieur
le prévenir les jeunes à l'audience
en cela il ya un deuxième bar qui est
créateur de pétro ivoire et le troisième
famille arnault le pdg de votre
communication le 1er mai sera donc la
convention entreprendre à 22 48 ans
48 ans et 27 ans après
vous même vous et les droits qu'il a
réalisés en coton noir
le deuxième aussi il a commencé à l'âge
de 72 ans
se nomme de n1 même aujourd'hui il n'est
pas mis la droite
de cette première on va devoir
maintenant et pas qu'en ce moment pas
tiens je
pensais la main tellement
mais qu'elle ne paraît difficile à
déterminer il n est pas contre la
liberté et réalise tout ce qui est en
vous allez c'est devenu bas elne et aux
sujets qui font multi et
c'est comme ça nous aider voir dont
hilary mariage est aussi se dote d'un
projectile est le nom qui s'effectue
donc ce sétois odem vous montrer un peu
que avec le travail acharné et avec une
dose de l'évidence on peut arriver à
réaliser tout ce qu'on me dit
alors
je veux vraiment pas aller un peu de
voir ici je ne peux pas vous parler de
quoi est plus que vous mais nous savons
tous que le boîtier est une grande fille
et moi qui a traversé de moments
difficiles
la population de bois qui doit être dj
de résilience pour pouvoir envoyer au
monde loin c'est pas le moment faut voir
les deux pays ne voit pas bien connus
dernière une loi cadbury
politique voire pouvoir gêner ou
même le savoir
alors les qualités pour être un bon
entrepreneur
contre vous a besoin
les trois sondages et de la haute loire
fouad allemande il faut être passionné
déterminer où cette passion n'est pas
différent il faut une bonne dose d
l'évidence une fois en l'air et un thème
développé des caribous d'ajouts se fixer
dans le petit ardennes et l'aisne
heureusement je faire d'autre même si la
peur dans le trac comme evans sont au
plus mal de soin de
rencontrer des personnes
destinées du monde et nous allions plus
loin
alors
ou mini jeux ne sont pas la raison de
citations à nous en matière de lips on
ne valent pas les gens en sentinelle ou
un kilo selon un ténor
ou selon la vérité dans un lieu mais on
évalue selon la bad
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]